[Music]
yes yes well this this game actually
reminds me of a story and the story
takes place in in Tilburg 1975 I gotta
play a 40 bring to the board bag but as
in buddy has fruit
he has apples and a vodka guru has
eating apple here I was playing ahem
jailer yes gather that you blaze Govinda
for threatening 14 dementia Luke yaa-hoo
a g1e play five boris sazanka I shall be
regarded reclaimed at that tournament
gather started with zero but then he
played brilliant game against Queen it
was a well balanced old game by costly
it's this position
she thought this up very have but told
about you have to go buy some toy
wakeful better yes
opponent once Knight takes c6 and then
Bishop Bishop gets away oh no what oh
Bishop gets away Bishop gets away Thank
You talkie
technically winning position he's just
exchanging pieces now it's although for
your key velocity
what's the Queen's xg4 what's your
looked
this is incredible hello crystal ball
hello crystal ball I I don't want to
play this match anymore I'm former
candidate famous [ __ ] legend and in
this 2600 Rick is is plugging me rook
versus rook I'm a famous [ __ ] legend
congratulations crystal ball but I I do
not want to play this match and that's
just [ __ ] single something if he takes
not camera takes on h6 visibly shopping
korean takes age six rock h3 Alexander
Grisha Magnus Carlsen plays three arias
Timken he's got 32 now 30 30 29 seconds
I it is very interesting how seconds
your conscience and life I play Dimitri
Kamarov I am on 45 different drugs when
i commentate chess in the flam in coming
like train on time he plays better ideas
7 b3 b5 he plays you for he blood
creates the position he is low on time
create a problem could be in this 7 King
g8 I might have aneurysm but I am still
commentating the game he gives check he
needs to avoid three time repetition he
avoids repetition here
since retract my ride jet skis complete
idiot what he doing in this position
[Laughter]
police green seed beat takes c4 he plays
magnus carlsen and Wesley is gonna get
wind of this and he's gonna like kill me
so here I want to protect protect the
fourth quare and okay so he coke 97
first of all thank you very much for
first attempt to play Magnus I really
appreciate the play which would be 3/2 -
man over 34 after Bishop e2 94 rugby 1
different it's a little bit unclear but
I think I have to thank you for your
gift to me the pattern what what am I
missing here yes Jen well in that case I
might take your queen right yeah you
know yeah sir I mean you've got to
understand Tesla that's you say he yes
it precise yes yes
yes what would xqc do in this position
of its being bang boom bing bang likes
to make a check and make a mate make a
check Mike a mate yes Jenny yes
Killa scale 97 rocky centrepiece Alan
then he goes we should be for Bishop c5
Knight c5 would you 7 shock me oh but I
miss Queen after to check but then I can
play rock up wonderful upon X takes 6
takes takes takes takes yeah another
another Mouse which they of course
stupid new Mouse the new Mouse it's
glitching again obviously glitching
examinees my backup Mouse this is the
reason I quit chess in 2005 you new
videos ago when I blink or boy I knew
there was a sooner 160 formula gaming a
new it's just it just gives with
computers for kids with computers of
iMac my backup Mouse of shits you you
don't want to see Magnus shouldn't beat
the minion because you know what it
plays badly new it's him
of course new Magnus to say but but
player will never becomes Grizzles me
know but sim no but here's a little bit
of potentially oh I just blundered oh my
god just strike just distract him he
tries just blundered you know if he
continues to train with me new he moved
to become you know 26:50 you know one
day you know oh my god oh jeez oh jeez
just one oh jeez Queen c1 check out jeez
I bet her maid oh no I wanted maid
oh my god I've wondered made a blunder
made this particular edge funded mate
just funny man wait that's good good I
think it's nice I'm just good guy makes
such a good guy think she could go
alright alright googa googa
shakka go go go go go oh uh no this is
completely lost for me he's got he's all
of a sudden playing much better until he
blunders it was just a horrible so clear
I think Luke McShane might be in some
trouble here after Queen takes c6 it's a
little bit it's a little bit complicated
let's see how handles this position
after Queen B - rock b1 he plays it's a
little bit see here I was quite
surprised at the game of Dingley ran
against Cara wanna master hitch for it
was well the position was quite unclear
I was very surprised by Fabiano's h4 and
we're left of night h3 instead it was
him
well the positions remained quite
complicated and this game wasn't that
smooth either it looked a little bit
unclear what was your feeling overall as
the game was transpiring it starts to
start how you play a smooth gamma just
play h5 in this position of such high
place with cameras am I supposed to win
a piece is opening and ticked all the
way to the end
it starts out how you play smooth game
guys Matthew I am a man of few words and
many actions especially on the bed I
don't talk much but I do a lot about the
positions a little bit complete okay
listen more if you try try you don't try
it on try oh but I mean of course no but
white is vegan no but I mean okay I
think why not but okay about this vegan
[ __ ] no but if you listen to me and you
listen listen to me no but okay a cover
seven very nice more than the white is
Vivian I mean if it takes I take you
know I remember there was a tournament
that I played with F and Geller and
Fabiano marijuana was also playing
that's horrible
well first of all in general I think the
position was relatively unclear in the
Petroff but but I had I have done quite
a bit of preparation in that regard and
in that tournament gather it was I
believe Tilburg 1934 it was Tilburg 1975
in Tilburg 1984 Kilberg 1974 1967 1954
was Tilburg 1681 and king louie xvi had
just gotten assassinated not know it was
1939 and poland had just been occupied I
was playing the pullian Bonaparte
in the second round this reminds me of a
story from from 1980 to Tilburg
then I was I was playing yes FM FM
Fabiano car
you wanna kill it
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
an indian feingold roar never play f3
999 Senta dudes